you know how England likes to call some
of its intersections circuses and it
doesn't make any sense well here's one
roundabout that actually deserves the
title even if it doesn't get it your
first thought upon seeing Swindon's
magic roundabout might be man the Brits
are really off their rockers lately but
this thing which is actually seven
roundabouts and one has been working for
60 years in a regular roundabout traffic
moves in one direction in Swindon circle
cars move both ways also drivers can
move from point A to point B without
having to drive all the way around the
circle but they do have the option to
use different routes to get to the same
exit in order to avoid traffic
it may look chaotic but it's actually
pretty efficient because it means less
fighting for space you just point your
vehicle toward where you want to go
yield to cars already in the midst of
the magic then drags it on the other
side many Americans may hate roundabouts
but they can actually cut serious
crashes by 30%
Swindon says its roundabouts has only
seen one fatal crash in the past five
years so to celebrate a town anniversary
they paraded over 60 vintage cars
through this feat of traffic engineering
is this madness
nope it's Swindon